foreign
[Music]
some other people that weren't involved
got involved in the teams
that's crazy man I'll call you back
and then you know someone's girl got hit
by accident and someone got hit by
accident that's when everybody's
starting to get involved
this is crazy
no we do a search before everybody comes
in yeah
the other one
foreign
I'll let you know okay good man no you
know who's really good at Eric
yeah yeah
thank you
they were awesome
respect respect you don't bring somebody
else
we'll take care of this one get him out
of here right now
he's on the way get him out of here
right now oh it's gonna be a Royal
Rumble come on man get him out of here
you're on the good side
in trouble
please
walk away
yo bring her in there there you go
y'all want to kill me
if you kill me you are gonna die nobody
wants to hurt you if you kill me
um
garage
[Music]
[Applause]
come here
thank you
this way
[Applause]
[Music]
stop
[Applause]
she got the option we're done
thank you
so just get her up and go I got it don't
worry about it go go
[Applause]
[Music]
um
don't worry
yeah I want to make sure you get through
[Applause]
all right
[Music]
373 now we need a mark unit to the
garage with the cage
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
[Applause]
hold on
that's just it
touch me crackers
[Applause]